kein ende in sicht das britische
parlament vertagt die bread entscheidung
und zwingt premier johnson bei der eu
einen aufschub zu beantragen
jünger digitale aber nur mit frauen
quote light die csu ringt auf ihrem
parteitag um reformen startschuss für
leseratten heute öffnet die frankfurter
buchmesse für alle ihre tore dabei im
trend
romy autoren und nachhaltigkeit
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend an diesem
samstag und ein herzliches willkommen
norbert könig ist auch dabei für den
sport genommen
seit dreieinhalb jahren quält der brh
exit die europäische politik heute hätte
das britische parlament die chance
gehabt fakten zu schaffen und den neuen
vertrag zu akzeptieren aber nein
eine entscheidung wurde wieder vertagt
das unterhaus fügt dem premierminister
damit eine weitere niederlage zu boris
johnson muss jetzt in brüssel um eine
praxis fristverlängerung bitten
draußen auf den straßen ein blaues
fahnenmeer
zehntausende protestierten mit viel
hingabe für ein neues referendum aus
london jetzt ja dem herrn ein
es kam wie schon zuvor so oft im
leidigen brh exit prozess der tag der
entscheidung sollte es werden die
entscheidung über den austritt aus der
eu über boris johnsons neuen deal doch
dann dieser änderungsantrag der mit 322
zu 306 stimmen angenommen wurde der
sogenannte letwin zusatz besagt dass die
entscheidung über das abkommen erst dann
rechtskräftig werden kann nachdem alle
dafür notwendigen gesetzesänderungen
ratifiziert sind die regierung entschied
daraufhin die abstimmung auf nächste
woche zu verschieben
per gesetz ist der premierminister
allerdings dazu verpflichtet in brüssel
eine verschiebung des austritts datums
zu beantragen
johnsons reaktion darauf ich werde keine
verlängerung mit der eu verhandeln und
das gesetz verpflichtet mich auch nicht
dazu es herrscht also erst einmal weiter
unklarheit der brief muss bis heute
mitternacht abgeschickt werden
in der debatte hatte johnson zuvor nicht
unbedingt zu erwarten de unterstützung
bekommen seine amtsvorgängerin brachte
ihn jene loyalität entgegen die ja ihr
stets vorenthalten hatte ich habe es
schon mehrfach gesagt und ich hoffe es
ist das letzte mal dass ich es sagen
muss er ein brett ohne abkommen
verhindern will muss für ein abkommen
stimmen
die opposition sieht das anders ich bin
mir der frustration und ermüdung die das
land und dieses parlament empfinden
bewusst aber wir können einfach nicht
für einen deal stimmen der sogar noch
schlimmer ist als der denn dieses haus
dreimal abgelehnt hat widerstand gegen
das abkommen zeigte sich heute auch auf
den straßen londons hunderttausende
forderten erneut ein zweites referendum
es gibt keinen guten den einfachen weg
praxis umzusetzen es funktioniert
einfach nicht deshalb müssen wir das
nochmal überdenken
alle haben die nase voll wir haben genug
von den lügen und wenn es lügen auf
beiden seiten gegeben hat warum dann
jetzt nicht noch ein referendum doch ob
es dazu kommt ist nach dem heutigen tag
genauso wahrscheinlich oder
unwahrscheinlich wie ein brett sind ohne
abkommen oder mit das chaos geht
schlicht weiter was nun ist jetzt die
frage wie ich direkt an unsere
korrespondenten in brüssel und london
weiter gebe die an der zimmermann boris
johnson zeigt sich unbeeindruckt von
dieser niederlage kann er den austritt
zum 31 oktober überhaupt noch schaffen
theoretisch ja auch wenn das die
unermüdlichen demonstraten hier hinter
mir nicht hoffen sie haben sich über die
heutige entscheidung sehr gefreut denn
praktisch ist ein austritt am 31 oktober
jetzt wirklich unwahrscheinlich boris
johnson müsste dafür den deal und das
gesamte gesetzespaket in den nächsten
zwölf tagen durchs parlament peitschen
selbst wenn er dort eine mehrheit hätte
wäre das ziemlich schwierig hatte aber
nicht so wie heute ja einmal mehr
eindrücklich erlebt haben
er wird also heute abend vor mitternacht
noch den brief mit der bitte um
verlängerung an brüssel ab schicken
müssen
gleichzeitig will er aber nächste woche
den deal und das gesetzespaket dem
parlament vorlegen
auch wenn er dort weitere niederlagen
einfahren sollte so kann das doch
langfristig seinem image helfen
er möchte sich ja in den augen des
wahlvolks als unbeirrbarer kämpfer für
den bhc rexit darstellen und in
möglichst naher zukunft dafür belohnt
werden
wie reagiert brüssel stefan leifert
reist kann ich langsam der geduldsfaden
er die geduld in sachen braig cit ist in
der eu sehr unterschiedlich ausgeprägt
aus paris hören wir dass emanuel makro
einer verlängerung sehr skeptisch
gegenübersteht und überhaupt keinen sinn
darin sieht jetzt noch einmal aufschub
zu gewähren
hier in brüssel ist man etwas gelassener
und geht davon aus dass wenn diese
verlierer verlängerungs bitte kommt dass
man ihr am ende auch stadt gibt die
frage vor der die eu steht ist wann man
dieses signal aussendet je länger die eu
damit wartet und zögert desto mehr hilft
man boris johnson druck aufzubauen auf
die opposition in london
am ende seinem deal zuzustimmen um eine
note die szenario am 31.10 zu verhindern
wenn die eu aber sehr früh dieses signal
aussendet zum beispiel schon morgen oder
übermorgen dann ist all denen in london
geholfen die mehr zeit wollen und
brauchen zb um ein neues referendum doch
noch irgendwie möglich zu machen
hier in brüssel heißt es jetzt für die
nächsten stunden erst einmal abwarten
jean claude juncker ließ eben über seine
sprecherin wissen dass er jetzt von
london erwartet möglichst schnell ein
signal zu bekommen wie es weitergehen
soll
also wieder alles auf einen dankeschön
stefan leifert und diana zimmermann
wie geht es weiter in großbritannien im
anschluss an diese nachrichten senden
wir dazu ein zdf spezial und auch online
können sie bei uns alle entwicklungen
weiter verfolgen im live blog auf
heute.de mitglied der eu zu werden davon
hatten albanien und nord mazedonien
geträumt und wurden gestern vom
eu-gipfel enttäuscht keine
beitrittsverhandlungen der nord
mazedonische regierungschef wulff
spricht von einer großen ungerechtigkeit
und will nun neuwahlen beantragen
die bürger sollten jetzt entscheiden
welchen weg deutschland einschlagen soll
lange haftstrafen für die anführer der
katalanische separatisten das hatte ein
spanisches gericht schon vor tagen
entschieden
die wut darüber reist aber nicht ab vor
allem in barcelona
dort waren die proteste die fünfte nacht
in folge eskaliert etwa 4000
demonstranten lieferten sich
straßenschlachten mit der polizei
zuvor hatten über eine halbe million
menschen friedlich protestiert madrid
erhöht jetzt den druck auf die
separatisten miteinander reden werde man
erst wenn die gesetze respektiert werden
nach münchen zu einem für csu
verhältnisse hoch kontroversen parteitag
csu chef markus söder will die partei
modernisieren frauen und junge starten
heute wurde sehr deutlich wie sehr vor
allem die geplante ausweitung der
frauenquote manche auf die palme bringt
von überflüssigem schmarrn war die rede
am ende gab es einen kompromiss kein
muss für mehr frauen sonnenuhr
aus münchen irgendwann plötzlich helle
aufregung ein deutlicher dämpfer für den
parteivorsitzenden markus söder
einen tag nach seiner wiederwahl seine
große parteireform gerät ins stocken
die frauenquote stößt auf massiven
widerstand bei delegierten
dabei sollte die csu jünger digitaler
und weiblicher werden
seit zehn jahren hat die csu eine quote
für spitzenämter die sollte ausgeweitet
werden auch auf vorstände auf kreisebene
jetzt hatten wir eine quote eingeführt
nach zehn jahren hat sie anscheinend ich
den effekt gebracht ihr zweimal sie noch
weiter ausführen verstehe ich nicht
vielen dank mit all diesen vorschlägen
hechelt der vorstand den grünen
hinterher und umgekehrt finde ich seinen
wahnsinn dass jetzt die hälfte des
parteivorstands aufsteht und versucht
hier einzugreifen in einer art und weise
es ist ein wahnsinn was hier macht
söderling kein die 40 prozent quote für
kreisvorstände wird nicht mehr
verpflichtend vorgeschrieben auf lasst
uns ein kompromiss weg gehen
dann empfehle ich dass wir jetzt
wirklich klug agieren und für den passus
markus blume tatsächlich dann legen wir
eine soll bestimmung machen
konfliktfrei geht es zu beim besuch von
annegret kramp karrenbauer die
schwesterparteien beschwören eine neue
einheit aber das was wir im letzten jahr
erlebt haben war zerstörerisch und das
darf uns nicht noch einmal passieren
der parteitag zum schluss befriedet und
markus söder hat die csu nach seinem
kompromiss bei der frauenquote so gut
wie geschlossen hinter sich seine große
parteireform wird mit grosser mehrheit
angenommen
ralf schumacher in münchen kurze bilanz
nach diesem parteitag überfordert markus
söder seine partei mit seinem
reformeifer oder bringt er sich dadurch
erst recht als kanzlerkandidat in
stellung
söder ist die unumstrittene nummer eins
in der csu und der gibt seiner partei
vor allem eins neues selbstbewusstsein
aber sein reformtempo das ist rasant als
regierungschef und in der partei die csu
muss neue wege gehen neue themen finden
wenn sie volkspartei bleiben wird so
dass analyse ist richtig aber er muss
aufpassen dass er nicht überzieht dass
die csu im folgen kann
die hitzige debatte um eine ausweitung
der frauenquote war ein klares
warnsignal söder musste zurückstecken
alles andere als geplant dass ihn manche
in seiner partei sogar ins rennen
schicken möchten für die nächste
bundestagswahl mag dem ehrgeizigen
csu-chef schmeicheln
aber der machtmensch söder weiß
natürlich nur zu gut dass das für ihn
deutlich zu früh käme einschätzung aus
münchen von ralf schumacher vielen dank
das gespräch haben wir am nachmittag
direkt nach ende des parteitags
aufgezeichnet zehn tage nach dem
anschlag auf die synagoge in halle an
der saale
tausende der opfer gedacht ein
rechtsextremist hatte zwei menschen
erschossen und zwei schwer verletzt
bei einem konzert auf dem marktplatz
setzen die besucher und stars ein
zeichen gegen ausgrenzung und hass mit
dabei künstler aus klassik und pop wie
alles merken mark foster oder max
giesinger veranstalter sind medien aus
der region die damit für ein friedliches
miteinander eintreten wollen
[Musik]
vor elf tagen ist die türkei in den
kurdengebieten in syrien einmarschiert
seither wurden mehr als 500 menschen
getötet hunderttausende sind auf der
flucht
das empört kunden und nichtkunden auch
in deutschland mehrere linke bündnisse
haben europaweit aufgerufen nach köln zu
kommen um zu demonstrieren
sie fordern den rückzug der türkischen
armee und einen stopp deutscher
rüstungsexporte an die türkei heiko rams
berichtet die stimmung war angespannter
als etwa 10.000 kunden in köln auf die
straße gingen
die veranstalter hatten mit deutlich
mehr teilnehmern gerechnet
auch in anderen deutschen städten
demonstrierten die kurden viele sind
verzweifelt wie fühle ich mich mein
vater jetzt seit vier tagen weiß ich
nicht ob er gestorben ist ob er im leben
ist nicht nur in der türkei sondern ein
grundsätzliches die unterdrückung leiter
ein teil unserer geschichte und deswegen
geht es nicht schlecht wir wollen
frieden führt einen krieg gegen die
kurden die kunden vertreiben
die kunden wissen wie schwer wir sind
total verzweifelt
nicht nur kunden sondern auch zahlreiche
deutsche protestierten gegen den
einmarsch türkischer truppen in syrien
auch bei einigen türken stoßen die
proteste auf verständnis ich finde
dieser angriff war nicht richtig der
einmarsch in syrien war unnötig sowohl
aus sicht der türkei als auch aus sicht
der syrer
sie sind doch unsere nachbarn und wir
leben seit 100 jahren gut zusammen
im vorfeld der demonstration waren
ausschreitungen befürchtet worden die
polizei war mit starken kräften vor ort
die demonstration sei friedlich
verlaufen so die polizei demonstriert
wurde heute auch in hamburg allerdings
wegen eines ganz anderen themas
tierversuche
tausende nahmen an einem protestmarsch
teil sie fordern die stilllegung eines
versuchslabors im niedersächsischen
bienenbüttel
dort sollen affen katzen und hunde
schwer misshandelt worden sein
ein tierschutz aktivist hatte heimlich
diese aufnahmen gemacht an den tieren
werden medikamente getestet die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt in der spd
war er viele jahre vor und querdenker
jetzt ist erhard eppler mit 92 jahren
gestorben
eppler arbeitete als minister in den
regierungen von willy brandt und helmut
schmidt schon in den 70er jahren
engagierte er sich für umweltschutz
später auch für die friedensbewegung
eppler leitete viele jahre die spd
grundwertekommission und war mehrfach
präsident des deutschen evangelischen
kirchentags bei der buchmesse in
frankfurt war heute erster publikumstag
mit einer neuerung erstmals gibt es die
bücher an den verlagsständen zu kaufen
auf viel interesse stoßen in diesem jahr
themen wie klima und natur und was auch
immer zieht sind prominente die sich zum
schreiben berufen fühlen denken klinge
nimmt uns mit auf die weltgrößte
bücherschau
dichtes gedränge immer dann wenn
prominente schauspieler ihre bücher
vorstellen
axel milberg hat einen roman über seine
jugend geschrieben
in ulrich tukurs werk spiegelt sich
seine leidenschaft für das fantastische
und für spannung und andrea sawatzki
präsentiert bereits den vierten band
über eine heitere romanheldin die ideen
kommen eigentlich aus mir denn die
hauptfigur ist die gundula bundschuh
das ist so quasi mein alter ego eine
frau um die 50 mit ihren sorgen und
nöten auch ein trend in diesem jahr
nachhaltigkeit und das klima ratgeber
und sachbücher über den menschen im
einklang mit der natur und die probleme
unserer zeit interessieren viele hier
auf der messe
ich finde es wichtig dass informationen
über klima und klimaveränderung auf ganz
vielen kanälen dargestellt werden
beschäftigung damit die muss heute sein
und auch der der konflikt darum wie wir
damit umgehen der muss heute sein
das deutsche gesicht der klimabewegung
ist luisa neubauer
sie schreibt vom ende der klimakrise und
übt nicht nur kritik sondern bietet auch
lösungen an
wir verstehen uns als passive listen das
sind nicht direkt optimisten den
optimismus schnell bequem und zwar
gefährlich bequemer lehnt sich zurück
weil alles wird gut wir sind populisten
das heißt wir sehen was möglich ist what
is possible
aber wir sehen auch dass wir dafür
kämpfen müssen zum ersten mal gleich die
messe einer großen buchhandlung denn am
gesamten wochenende darf auch gekauft
werden
und jetzt bist du dran norbert mit
fußball bundesliga und enttäuschten beim
ja und automatisch freut sich der gegner
einen punkt geholt aber gefühlt gewonnen
mit zwei treffern in der ersten minute
und in der nachspielzeit verdirbt der fc
augsburg dem rekordmeister den
vorläufigen sprung an die tabellenspitze
durch das 2 2 bleibt es für die bayern
bei nur vier siegen in acht
saisonspielen nationalspieler niklas
süle obendrein musste wegen einer
schweren knieverletzung früh vom platz
freiburgs hoffnungen auf platz eins
beendet aufsteiger union berlin 2 zu 0
leipzig wolfsburg genauso 1 zu 1 wie
werder gegen hertha bsc
düsseldorf bezwingt mainz 05 1 0 am
abend das borussen duell dortmund
gladbach gestern frankfurt leverkusen
drei zu null
gladbach bleibt mindestens bis morgen
tabellenführer dann könnte eventuell
schalke die spitze übernehmen
dortmund kann nachher theoretisch von
neun auf drei springen in der unteren
tabellenhälfte feld mainz von 13 auf 16
union klettert dafür von 16 auf 14 köln
und paderborn morgen im direkten duell
im aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr
ausführlich das topspiel dortmund gegen
gladbach zu gast ist cacau der
integrationsbeauftragte des dfb
gold silber bronze so lautet die
erfreuliche ausbeute für deutschland am
dritten tag der bahnrad
europameisterschaften in apeldoorn in
den niederlanden gleich zwei medaillen
gab es in der einerverfolgung der frauen
für die neue europameisterin franziska
bronze und lisa brennauer im deutschen
finale schaffte browser über die 3000
meter persönliche bestzeit und war knapp
1,2 sekunden schneller als die
titelverteidigerin brennauer außerdem
gab es bronze im sprint turnier für
näher und so friedrich tennisprofi julia
görges ist auf gutem weg beim wta
turnier in luxemburg ihren titel
erfolgreich zu verteidigen
nach dem souveränen zwei satz sieg im
halbfinale gegen die kasachen regina
wartet morgen im endspiel french open
siegerin lena ostapenko aus lettland
und neuseelands rugby-spieler sind wild
entschlossen zum dritten mal
nacheinander weltmeister zu werden im
wm-viertelfinale in tokio gelang ein
klares 46 zu 14 gegen mit-favorit irland
die show beginnt mit dem rituellen und
respekt einflößenden hkd nieren die
zunge zeigen und zugleich das spiel an
sich reißen in der sechsten minute die
ersten drei punkte durch mol ungarn und
dann überreden die all blacks irland im
wahren sinne des wortes wird mit einem
erfolgreichen versuch zum 22 zu 0 zur
halbzeit
gegen ende wird sie just under seine 112
kilo körpergewicht in die waagschale und
sichert irland die letzten punkte die
all blacks gewinnen mit 46 zu 14
bedanken sich beim publikum und werden
im halbfinale gegen england wieder den
trucker aufführen
morgen gibt's im nordwesten regen im
südosten strahlt die sonne die details
hat gleich christa steht für sie das
heute journal um viertel vor elf mit
christian sievers wir sagen tschüss
wünschen ihnen noch ein unbeschwertes
wochenende und sind morgen wieder da
wenn sie mögen und hier geht's jetzt
weiter mit dem zdf spezial
[Musik]
guten abend der sonntagmorgen wird ganz
unterschiedlich in köln erwarten wir
sogar teils kräftigen regen und nur 14
grad in münchen dagegen strahlenden
sonnenschein und 24 grad mit föhn
unterstützung warum was passiert ja im
moment zieht wie an einer kette immer
neuer regen von südwest nach nordost
über uns hinweg dieses muster haben wir
auch in der nacht am stärksten regnete
noch im schwarzwald später verschiebt
sich das in die pfalz der regen der
bleibt also immer auf diesen korridor
und dadurch bleibt der weg aus bayern
und aus sachsen und da bleibt da nicht
nur der regen weg da gibt es teils
richtig strahlendem sonnenschein von der
ostsee da bleibt aber grau bis nach
nordrhein-westfalen und ins saarland
hier teilweise auch den ganzen tag
dauerregen nur an der nordsee kommt
nicht ganz so viel vom himmel da gibt es
immerhin auch mal eine stunde sonne was
mehr ist als unter den regenwolken da
sieht man sie gar nicht aber ab einer
linie oberer in berlin
da ändert sich das dann komplett und es
sind zehn stunden sonne möglich diese
zweiteilung sieht man auch an den
temperaturen 13 bis 19 grad unter
regenwolken 20 bis sehr milde 26 grad
mit föhn unterstützung am alpenrand und
zu mild für diese jahreszeit bleibt es
auch noch in der neuen woche ab dienstag
beginnt dann mit einem hoch eine
trockenere phase